well dave portnoy is a frequent guest on
this program we're proud of that
he is a genuine supporter of small
business businesses he built one himself
he's been watching as america's
independent business sector is destroyed
and on thursday in frustration he
announced that he is creating a fund for
small businesses to help them survive
dave portnoy is the founder of barstool
sports he joins us to explain this fund
dave thanks for coming on you said you
were going to do this i knew that you
would i'm impressed that you have
tell us how it works yeah so i
appreciate you letting us back on so
basically we donated 500 grand half a
mil of our own money
and then we said we're gonna raise more
funds from our readers
uh friends we may have who are fortunate
whatever it may be will feature a new
business
every single day they tell us how much
they need a struggling small business
the only requirement their payroll has
to be on and then we'll
hit that goal and move for the next
business once we hit that goal we'll hit
the next
hopefully we can save as many small
businesses or bridge the gap really
till cove it's done and they can go back
to earning a living
by the way when we talk to all these
people um that's all they want they
don't want to hand out they want the
opportunity to actually work
but they want you know the chance to get
back so we put t-shirts on sale last
night we raised
i think we sold a million dollars in a
couple hours of that
i think this can be tens of millions of
dollars and you know
i didn't think i'd be the guy doing it
i'd rather be sitting on a beach
bet on horses drinking but nobody else
is going to do it we have this big
platform so uh we're going to try to
help as many small businesses as we can
if you want to donate
i asked to come back on thank you tucker
i don't think i've ever done that
but you have such a big platform so if
you want to help
it's barstoolsports.com fund
you can donate and 100 we're not going
to take a penny of it
everything goes right back to the
businesses who need help right now
because as we've seen
as we've heard nobody else is going to
do it so we better do it
that's right no one else has done it so
you said the one requirement is the
payroll has to be on in other words
you have to be paying your employees you
got to be employing people
correct because we want it it's so hard
to help everybody
we want to kill two birds with one stone
it's not just the business owners
like the perfect example is barely's a
place in longmeadow
uh they're on the verge of going out of
business he wasn't gonna ask for help mr
brella the owner
he kept his payroll on today i met with
la and contro the guy he's actually
going to hannity next
he made a video out in the snow he
because you can only have outdoor dining
we had a blizzard in new york and he's
making you know with his staff eating a
nice dinner
he had to lay off 40 of his 45 people so
we want to help not only the business
but we also want to pay our employees so
they can go
they can have christmas all that so have
a payroll that's
still on keep your business tell us how
much you need
and not only that we're going to get
your gold tucker and then once you're in
our program we're not going to disappear
so
if you need 75 grand a month you have it
till this pandemic's done we're not
going to go two months
and then on month three we disappear
because what good does that do
so we'll do it to the life of this thing
and get through
hopefully this summer at the very latest
but as many businesses as we can help
is better than nothing i just got to get
back to
first of all bless you for doing this i
love it and i know the people you're
helping will be grateful
you're the founder of a of a big digital
property
but it's not blackstone you're not in
finance you're paying 50
tax rates like every other wage earner i
would expect what about the really rich
people
why aren't they doing honestly why
aren't they why isn't amazon doing this
yeah i don't know why you know i don't
have those answers because to be honest
i wasn't planning on doing it till
somebody mark the mark uh
lemonis he's like why you put your money
where your mouth was i was like you know
what
he's right so we jumped out and do it i
don't have the answers for anybody else
i don't pretend to i think it's crazy
that i pay all these taxes and the tax
money isn't going for this
very use to help other people i have no
idea
it's one of those things you look around
and everyone's talking and pointing and
doing no one's doing
so that's how we jumped into it we're
not a
we're not a charity organization we
we've raised money obviously in the past
it's a huge undertaking
but you know sometimes you're going to
do it and that's one of those situations
i don't advance is why nobody else has
why the government has super rich people
by the way if you're a rich friend of
mine
i'm going to be hitting you up i'm going
to become a sales guy so get ready for
that call
but yeah i have no idea i have no idea i
don't have answers right now i know
if nobody's doing something somebody has
to do something
bar stool sports slash fund dave portnoy
i hope you raise a ton
again thank you for doing this good to
see you thank you